dear Sarah I think this is a really
important question because it actually
goes even beyond simply the relationship
of the US and the Arab world I think
it's got a lot to do with attitudes
between religious cultures and
civilizations and especially in relation
to the Muslim world and while obviously
I'm not going to deny that there are
real political issues and real
differences as to how these are
perceived and how people think we should
be resolved at the heart of the problem
that you're pointing to I think is the
question of respect and people want to
be respected and what to feel that their
dignity is not something that is just
referred to verbally but is real in
terms of the way people understand the
other and the way they relate to the
other and in order to do that we need
basic education the knowledge of Islam
within the United States in particular
but it's actually not just United States
is abysmal and I find that amongst the
Muslim world there's very little real
knowledge of what Christianity and
Judaism another religion stand for so we
need first of all to give people proper
information so it can treat the other
religious culture or something to be
valued Express and even celebrate it and
not god forbid to be something to be
disparaged and when we have the basis of
respect I think and we're able to engage
one another and serious conversations to
find ways to resolve our differences and
misunderstandings